[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de La
Crónica de medio ambiente soy María
Clara calle getty o hacerlo fue el
llamado actuar que se hizo en la edición
número 14 de la semana del clima de
Nueva York realizada entre el 19 y el 25
de septiembre fue una de las últimas
oportunidades para reunir a los líderes
más influyentes de la acción climática
antes de la Cumbre de la ONU que este
año será en Egipto en noviembre la 27 y
se hizo el tiempo que la mayoría de los
jefes de estado estaban en Nueva York
para la asamblea general de la ONU la
semana de clima se concentró en 11 temas
en torno construido energía justicia
ambiental finanzas naturaleza y también
habló de políticas vida sostenible
transporte alimentación industria y
resiliencia
pero la semana del clima No es solo para
exigir más acciones sino también un
espacio para probar como si es posible
mitigar el calentamiento global y long
island en el estado de Nueva York es un
ejemplo la isla más grande de Estados
Unidos quiere convertirse en un centro
de energía limpia Allí se construirán
parques eólicos en altamar capaces de
generar electricidad para más de un
millón de viviendas También tienen un
centro de paneles solares que nutren a
4.200 hogares Y que reducen en 20 mil
toneladas métricas por año las emisiones
de CO2 Lo que equivale a sacar 4000
autos de circulación además están
reemplazando El combustible de gas
natural por gas natural renovable e
hidrógeno
las empresas y los gobiernos no son los
únicos grandes actores los jóvenes
también están siendo protagonistas del
cambio ya sea educando a las comunidades
sobre la crisis climática uniéndose para
evidenciar las desigualdades ambientales
o exigiendo metas más ambiciosas por eso
Franz 24 se unió a la organización
internacional
para organizar un foro en la semana del
clima de Nueva York sobre las voces de
los jóvenes que piden justicia climática
de Cara a la Cup 27
y una de las participantes fue la
abogada colombiana María Alejandra
Aguilar quien hace parte de ambiente y
sociedad y además fue elegida como
fellow para la resiliencia en la copa 27
al ganar una beca de los campeones del
clima de la ONU María Alejandra
bienvenida Franz 24 y cuéntenos primero
Cómo fueron esas acciones de los jóvenes
en la semana del clima en Nueva York
Hola María Clara Muchas gracias por la
invitación Bueno yo creo que la juventud
ha sido una fuerza catalizadora de
acción en movimiento que se basa en la
interseccionalidad y que reconoce que la
acción climática tiene que ser justa no
donde resolver las múltiples inequidades
es determinante y directamente
relacionado a poder enfrentar la crisis
climática en la semana de clima de Nueva
York se dieron varios espacios liderados
por jóvenes una marcha multitudinaria el
viernes convocada por jóvenes y en mi
caso yo participé en dos espacios you
for claymar que fue un evento paralelo y
además en una sesión de diálogo que como
mencionabas fue apoyada por the nation
concervency el grupo de jóvenes que
viene formando desde 2017 que se llama
conversations que ha buscado
precisamente Resaltar el trabajo de los
jóvenes en la región de las Américas
ambiente sociedad y France 24 este
espacio pues reunió jóvenes de diversas
regiones del mundo y fue un espacio muy
enriquecedor porque nosotros trabajamos
desde distintos ángulos por la acción
climática desde el activismo desde las
bases hasta la incidencia política en
espacios nacionales e internacionales y
esto pues es relevante no visibilizar y
dar plataforma a nuestros llamados Y a
propósito de esa plataforma de la que
usted habla el programa campeones del
clima de la ONU en 2021 creó un programa
en el que beco a cinco jóvenes para que
participaran en la copa 26 esta vez
repitieron el programa y fueron ocho los
elegidos entre más de mil aspirantes de
80 países del mundo y usted fue la
elegida para hablar de la resiliencia
que tanta influencia realmente pueden
tener los jóvenes en esta 27
Bueno yo creo que este espacio y esta
iniciativa pues ha sido muy valiosa es
un logro que reconoce que el rol de los
jóvenes tienen en la agenda climática
pero es importante decir que no hemos
sido elegidos Por el simple hecho de ser
menores de 30 años sino porque tenemos
una experiencia profesional práctica de
académica relevantes en acción climática
desde distintos frentes y contextos y a
pesar de que creo que ha sido una gran
experiencia creo que la la capacidad
real de incidencia en en la agenda
problemática en la Cup es baja la
participación sé que puede ser un poco
limitada y en mi opinión hay mucho
espacio para poder aprovechar nuestras
capacidades y fomentar una participación
más efectiva no Y usted ha trabajado
también con temas de género y medio
ambiente cuéntenos Por qué los climas
extremos afectan más a las mujeres
la crisis climática es una asunta de
género no la vulnerabilidad de cambio
climático potencializa las desigualdades
relacionadas a los roles de género
impuestos Y tenemos evidencia de que la
violencia basada en género incrementa
cuando hay desastres climáticos un
ejemplo súper claro es que el tráfico de
personas aumentan un 20 y 30% y el
cambio climático expone a las mujeres y
a las niñas a un mayor riesgo de
explotación sexual violencia doméstica
riesgo de matrimonio infantil
desplazamiento entre otros a pesar de
esta realidad la participación de las
mujeres en las negociaciones de cambio
climático es deficiente para la cop26
que fue el año pasado solo el 39% de los
negociadores de las delegaciones fueron
mujeres y el cambio climático no afecta
sólo el 50% de la población Así que un
llamado muy puntual para esta cop27 es
que al menos haya paridad de género en
los equipos negociadores y Esperamos que
así sea María Alejandra Gracias por
estar con nosotros en France 24
Gracias y hasta aquí La Crónica de medio
ambiente ustedes sigan con la
programación de nuestro canal
[Música]